Speaker 1: Hey, one quick note. Madison
Cawthorn, thankfully as one of the most
radical members of Congress to be elected in
2020, was defeated in a Republican primary.
Good. He'll be leaving on January, whatever
the date is, 2023, when the new Congress is
inaugurated. Except it appears that he has
already left. There's a very interesting
report from The Citizen Times. Madison Cawthorn
vacates office before end of term constituents
calls go unanswered. He has stopped working.
Madison Cawthorn is no longer working. He's
still an elected official. He's still a member of
Congress. He isn't working anymore. And this is
just really instructive about what happens when
you vote for these people. None of these people
want to work. This is the exact same story as
what we saw with Donald Trump during the campaign
over the summer in 2020. Trump, by many reports,
had essentially stopped all presidential duties.
He wasn't receiving the presidential daily
briefing. Even when he was receiving it. He
wasn't really paying attention, but he wasn't
even ostensibly receiving it. And then in the
period between the November 2020 election and
when Trump ultimately left the White House,
he wasn't doing any work. These people don't
actually want to work. They don't want to work.
Madison Cawthorn has just left. He has abandoned
the job that, quite frankly, he was never actually
interested in doing. It was sort of like it
was sort of like college, right? He thought,
this sounds kind of cool, but he didn't actually
want to do the stuff that's required. People
around him were a little bit creeped out. He did a
terrible job, messed up a bunch of stuff, and then
ended up kind of going back home to live with his
family. They're not really sending their best. And
this is just another example where, again, I would
say to you, too, Republicans, are you so committed
to the party that you would quite literally
rather a guy who goes home instead of doing
the job than a Democrat who cares? And I know
the answer for many of them, the answer is yes,
it is. It's that simple. And for many of them,
especially the ones who say our elected officials
shouldn't even be doing that much, it's extra
exciting to see a guy go, I'm not going to do
anything. I'm just going home because they don't
want government doing stuff. So as insane as this
is. You will find defenders of Madison Cawthorn
who will say, I think it's good he doesn't need
to be there voting on all sorts of stuff that
government shouldn't even be involved in. He has
abandoned his job. Will have all of the clips from
all of these segments on our Instagram, which you
can find at David Pakman show. We're going to take
the shortest of breaks and then the show continues